Kamala's asking how do you get people to
take me seriously when he's 14 years old
I think don't even worry about it just
make the videos with whatever it is you
want to make them about and put them out
there and if the content is serious and
worthy being taken seriously they'll
take you seriously I think it's you know
content is king the only thing the
biggest thing for me I found beat I was
that young entrepreneur I was 19 and I
was telling the guys three times my age
and feeling like why would they talk to
me I'm 19 these guys have pH D's they're
professors you know they've done well I
don't have a back I'm label scientists
I'm gonna sell this scientific software
to scientists when I'm not a scientist
it starts with taking yourself seriously
right like I am good at what I do I can
add value to the world and I believe
that to my core right if you don't
actually believe it there's no way
you're gonna convince somebody else
right memberís story about Nelson
Mandela who went into prison when he was
jailed and he refused to be called
anything besides mr. Mandela he wouldn't
he just refused he commanded respect
right this is a prisoner he's a prisoner
dude he's if he's in jail and they had
to call him mr. Mandela to get anything
done and so like you got a command
respect if you provide value people will
listen to you and they'll get a sense
quickly like even walking into the room
right are you like this are you
confident are you hi are you the lion
are you about to take on the world are
you like oh I'm like I'm this
fourteen-year-old kid and I don't you
know please give me a deal right like
already already you set the tone for
what's gonna happen that day right so it
starts with you taking yourself
seriously yeah that's a big like mental
twist that took me a while to figure out
but you get your head around that
I'm stoppable man unstoppable well
that's pretty well how do you have
access to that how do you have access to
what to to making that paradigm shift
it's it's back to like everything we've
been talking about in the past call
right the environment that you have
around you your your belief system you
know what do you consume on a daily
basis that makes you want to be
something bigger than yourself and
believe that you can because all of us
we have these moments of boldness right
you have a day when you like wake up at
2:00 in the morning oh got this great
idea it's gonna be amazing
and then where does it go like you wake
up the next day and it's gone yeah right
you've killed yourself like it wasn't
that the idea sucks now he's just you
don't believe in it anymore because it
was too bold and made you step out too
far and then you're gonna retreat back
so it's consistently having things in
your environment that stretch you and
force you to go out and do something
bigger like you want videoman you last
year refused to do any video like no I'm
the guy behind the camera
my friends on Facebook you know will
laugh at me whatever right like you were
in this shell that you refused to come
out of no matter how much I like rich
man come on you got this right whatever
you know your wife was supporting you
right and then finally like I forced you
on camera and this now open up your
shell and now it's now now for you being
in front of a camera at your home is no
big deal like you're used to it you're
getting used to we're doing our hangouts
you're fine you're being open and honest
now the next step is like going out and
doing it in public or in the backyard or
like I get it I was there right there's
still times when I feel uncomfortable
then there it's like any new situation
you're gonna get in that but what always
helps me is understanding that hey I'm
good at what I do I can provide value to
these people that I'm gonna work with
and once I acknowledge that and and
believe that the rest takes care of
itself
like you've set yourself up for failure
before you even walk in that room
because you don't have the confidence in
yourself